[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です2018年いよいよ
あるとポップが迫って来ましたと言ってもあの僕は決して
なんかができるわけではございませんがぁワールドカップは誰でも自由に熱く応援する
ことができるので僕も僕なりに
ずにマグカップを応援したいと思っておりますそこで私はじめシャツをなんと
をバドワイザーイレブンに選ばれておりますワールドカップっていうのは誰でも自由に
多いできるっていうのを皆さんに伝える使命がございます全て僕も僕なりにちょっと
頑張って応援したいので今回なんと
木月文の逆門の者やリーダーの皆さんにれ c でして
[音楽]
艶リビングを学ぼうと思います
ないんですよ自由なんです柔軟であの僕もチェリーだとしてこのちゃんと応援すること
も
ワールドカップだったら梅雨なんでチアリーディングというものを本気で学んで全力で
ワールドカップを応援したいと思いますもう
しているみたいな早速愛さと言っていきましょうでは
[音楽]
こんにちはこんにちはー
視聴皆さんのチアリーダーチャリうっていうものを教わりに行きました
はい
今日人女子くれるの
私たちはプロスペっ所なるチアリーディング協会のオールスタープロ jr リーダーズ
ですはじめしゃちょーさんの熱い気持ちとってもよく伝わりました
もっと熱くほんと自由に
はいそうですそれでは今日1日頑張っていきましょうありがとうございます
今日始め所 cancer に覚えていただく売りを今から
披露したいと思いますしっかり見てくださいねこれをしますはい
でお願いしまーす
ああああああ
おいいいいいいい
car
[拍手]
あろん
やっすごかったですありがとうございまーだよ僕が覚えられるようになるって多分
ことでもダンスちょっと怒ってるんですよ大丈夫一番大事なのはダンスよりも気持ち
ですか
気持ちを応援する気持ちが一番大事です
はいや早速
準備体操からと言いましょうかはいよろしくお願いします
逆じゃ伸びてると交換ジャンプが大事ですなるほどねっ
[音楽]
入っている
ないやん
ええええええ
me
[拍手]
たここまでは準備運動ということでここからは本気でもっと圧をかけていきたいと
おもいます
引き続きよろしくねはい
女優しては頑張りますよ
[拍手]
笑顔ねはいじゃあまず笑ってみましょう
せーのフッカーんああ素敵ですもうねーよ
ああああああ
大括弧を上げると遠くから見てもすごい道に見えるので
飲んだんっ動意づいてはパフォーマンスの振り移しになりたいと思います宜しくお願
宜しくお願いします
笑顔ではー
[音楽]
このポーズが終わったらおでん
していえーい
yeah
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
wh
スコープを持ってませんこれええええええ
ああああああ
ん
あああああああああああ
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
いきますよ
入った
ぱ car car 2 pac いい
0なのでもうち道
car
ああああああ
rar
parse parse
ああああ
ああああああ
ステちゃんと素敵
[音楽]
[拍手]
無理たーーー
俺にチアリーダーなどで気ねーよ
メッシュ調査何やってるんですか
こんな事でへこたれないでください
ワールドカップ応援するんでしょ一緒に最後まで頑張りましょう
いや
僕なんても無理ですよ
[音楽]
yeah
今学びましょうございます
頑張るかん
シャア車
なんかやる気が出てきましたカラー
ああ
ああああああ
[音楽]
can
[拍手]
[音楽]
oh
yeah
はいというわけでみなさんおつかれさまでしたはーい
というわけでワールドカップはですね誰でも水に応援することができます
僕は今回チアリーダーの応援を学ばせていただいたので
ワールドカップは者リーダーっぽく応援してみようかなと思っております
僕みたいにサッカーのことはあまり詳しくない人でも厚く自由に応援できるので皆さん
もぜひ応援してください皆で盛り上げていきましょう
[拍手]
おっけどねぇ
ねぇ
はいというわけで jr リーダーの便習得させていただきました
やってみて思ったんですけど本当に何か全身の筋力を使うというか
運動量だけじゃなくて映画をずっと座安ことなくいつしなきゃいけないので難しかった
です
入って行き出窓ワイザーなんですけどもうこちらがネットワールドカップ限定の間に
なっておりますぞあーこれ
なんですけど図1色が違うしファングカップです
かっこいいです限定版の間にシールがついていま
こちらにあ
でこの限定缶を盗んでこちらのシールでポイントを集めると僕が今着ているこちらの
ジャンパーとユニフォームが与えます
応募してみてください見た試合の中で一番熱かった熱いと思った選手を選ぶ
man on the 末ということもやっておりますみなさんぜひ参加してみて
ください
愛汁でこちらの url にいろんな情報を全て
ありますのでぜひ皆さん初らかのアクセスして画像を見てください
他とバドワイザーイレブンの動画お世話になりますので接続だった是非見てください
行ってしまいましたはいみなさんワールドカップの応援 b グルはないんですよ
国みたいだねサッカーのことはあまり知らない人でもこんなに楽しく望遠できて
ば声だも美味しいした教えせよすべく皆さんも数え茶飲みながら応援も楽しんでまるで
トップも楽しいね
ハッピーになりましょうガーン
me
ええええええ
あっはっ